first let's just unpack the fact that
you've just dropped probably the most
important lesson in life
which is that your body
has intelligent design
and it is constantly sending you signals
and when something shrinks you depletes
you
makes you feel like you're hiding
uh
that is a
hugely important signal to pay attention
to and one of the simple secrets in life
is
spend more time
with people
and doing experiences that expand you or
energize you and you also said something
important it has nothing to do with
whether or not something is easy
or something is difficult and has
everything to do
with the kind of energy that you feel
when you're either in that experience or
you are with
those people that are meant for you and
so that's number one
uh in terms of just such an important
takeaway and it took me a really [ __ ]
long time to to realize that that a lot
of why my life was so hard
is because i was spending time either
with people that depleted me
or in situations that depleted me or in
a job
that depleted me and you know i can
remember like it was yesterday being
29 years old and being here in boston
and we had just moved here and i could
not get a job i used i had been a public
defender uh working for legal aid in new
york city straight out of law school and
then we moved to boston for my husband's
for my husband to go to business school
and i was not a member of the bar so i
couldn't practice law in a courtroom so
the only job i could get was in a law
firm which is the exact
opposite
from walking into a courtroom and
representing people i was walking into a
high-rise and into an office
and then sitting at a desk all day
researching and writing i'm highly
dyslexic it's really hard for me to
focus my brain that way i would be
sitting on that commuter rail
with almost like a visceral
hangover feeling um don't go don't go
like my whole body you know when you're
in a relationship or you're sleeping
with somebody or you're walking into a
job that doesn't feel right and too many
of us and especially women we stay in
these situations like it's some kind of
obligation to endure it or to fix
somebody else so it feels better and you
know i went into that job every single
day for more than a year and then i got
pregnant thank god because while i was
on maternity leave i not only had
massive postpartum depression
but when i finally
got stabilized from the postpartum
depression i had this awakening that was
visceral i said to my husband i can't
go back to work i cannot do it the idea
of walking in there now that i've been
separated from it is making me
physically ill and then he said well no
problem we've just bought this house
uh we can't afford it unless you're
working so you gotta go make sixty
thousand dollars so now i had a problem
i had four weeks before i had to walk
back into that job and i had to find a
job that made 60 000 and boy did i get
to work and i think if you frame
life change often particularly like
getting a job like a problem to
solve sometimes it makes it easier to
figure out how to solve it some
motivation
to get by even though getting by for one
versus the other is totally different i
believe that we're stepping into an age
where we're going to learn how to tap
into our body and like really be able to
sense truth and truths and lies and
indicators we're just we're just going
to be more in touch physically with how
our outside reality makes us feel to be
a guide for us i think that's what's
going to be called of us in this day and
age where we can't even we don't even
know if we're watching the news and it's
true or false we just we don't know
anything what is real what is not
um
why is it what why is it that we don't
listen to those cues we don't
we don't listen to that little voice and
sign that has that quick little like you
know or like
the answer is simple
you've been trained not to
how what what is it that trains us not
to
travel the aspects that we overlook in
our life that we do on a repetitive
basis that go
not the body not the intuition out here
you were trained as a child
but if you did
what your instincts told you to do
that you would get in trouble
or somebody would be mad at you like
that's how you parent children
through threats and intimidation i mean
come on i'm a parent like that's how i
just yeah
but not really because you know as a kid
you want to keep the peace you want to
make sure that you're not uh you know
like it goes back to survival
you are hardwired to be part of a pack
and the pack that you're born into
for better or for worse is the one that
you're
wired
in your dna to stay connected to
and so
what happens
is you know we can talk about the range
of having a household that's safe
where you're just worried about your mom
being upset you're just worried about
dad not yelling and it's all
subconscious
you're just reading the cues
and so you know all you want to do is
dance and play and that's what your
intuition is telling you and to play
your records and to make it and it's
like can you shut up it's been like
you know and so
you learn
to stop
listening to what's in your heart and
soul and to prioritize reading the cues
and then that only gets reinforced when
you go to school when it becomes
part of your uh
your your biological and your your
growth evolution
to form friendships and so your brain
has this moment where it goes from
accepting and loving you exactly as you
are to suddenly your brain turns into
the sorting hat from harry potter
and now
you look around and instead of seeing a
world that you want to explore
you see the groups you belong to and the
groups that you don't and your mind is
doing this as a way to protect you is
all evolutionary stuff
in terms of keeping you safe
and so instead of going to sit with the
sports kids or you know the kids that
look different than you or the kids that
are artsy you start to go oh well i
can't go there because i don't have nice
clothes and i can't go there because i
don't look like those kids and i can't
go there because and you start to
literally
talk yourself out of
following the pull of your heart i can't
possibly go out for the play because all
the kids will you know question my
sexuality if i'm a guy i can't possibly
quit the football team because my dad is
going to be pissed off at me
life taught you
to stop listening to your own instincts
and part of the one of the greatest
opportunities
of your life as an adult
because once you're 18 you get to say
you have way more control than you think
you do you get to say what job you want
to go and pursue you get to say
what you want to do for a living you get
to say who you're going to love and how
you're going to live your life
and
one of the greatest gifts of your
adulthood is coming back home to
yourself and learning how to remove the
crap
that has been put
on top of your intuition the anxiety the
people pleasing the imposter syndrome
the penalties
the penalties
you know there are some like let's take
an example of somebody who grows up in a
wildly
uh conservative religious household
who is gay
and
being themselves means
that your family kicks you out yeah
your entire existence
is something you're hiding
your identity is what you're hiding
because the messaging
at you and the consequences as a child
were so severe
and so you know people experience this
there's not a single adult who has not
had life or abuse or trauma or some
situation
scream at you you can't be you
it's not or you got to change if you
want me to like you you got to change if
you want mom to be happy you gotta not
be
totally yourself
if you want dad to love you
and then if you've had issues like
abandonment or you've had issues like
discrimination or abuse
the
experience of those things makes you as
a child question there well there's got
to be something wrong with me because if
there weren't something wrong with me my
father would still be here at the house
if there weren't something wrong with me
i wouldn't have been abused like this
this is sort of what the child brain
does it turns it back at you and so this
is
what every adult needs to
repair
in order to tap back into
the wisdom that is inside you and to
hear
what your intuition and your soul is
trying to tell you
and the other reason why it's very hard
for people to hear
is because
you're so busy
you're so busy running from one thing to
the next you're kind of on autopilot
you're doing this thing you're not even
present and so it requires a slowing
down
and that's one of the greatest gifts of
the pandemic i think for a lot of people
that's why you're seeing the great
resignation and so many people quitting
their jobs that's why you're seeing
divorces skyrocket that's why you're
seeing
people
really
have a reckoning with themselves about
what's working what's not working
because the pandemic hit the pause
button and you didn't have anywhere that
you could go you couldn't run to target
or to get a
uh cup of coffee with a friend in order
to just be busy
you had to stay put very very well said
we could just stop there and that's
enough information for people to feast
on and just like go with right because
there's
there's there's two parts the first is
your is your
familial situation it's your it's your
upbringing it's your
childhood trauma and patterning
and then the other part is uh culture
and you know what your environment is
and how
everything is designed to distract you
um
and take you out of
your relationship with your inner self
your inner child whatever it is that you
want to call it um and and and place
fear i think that's been a big part of
kind of this last couple years is
there's just so much fear propaganda
or fear porn as they would call it you
know it's just it's and it's and it's
crippling for for for so many people
um so let's start with the first one
which i think is the the one that uh
we have control over both of them but i
think it's almost the hardest one and
that's your own your own programming
from childhood i mean i'm fascinated
with psychology and fascinated with why
we are the way we are
and it's taken me into my late 30s to
really get a grasp on sort of the
patterns in my life showing up and the
um you know childhood traumas that
happen with mom with dad and what we're
what we're looking for to resolve and
then how we act ourselves and it's all
in the it's all in the parents and
so
you know i think that's one of them i
think that's probably one of the most
important things that i have dealt with
personally is just taking a step forward
into those
those realities and maybe the most
important thing my therapist said to me
was that no one holds the keys it was
like i wanted to once i started
unpacking it was like i wanted to blame
mom or dad apologize and then everything
will be okay and it's like that doesn't
make it okay you have to
you have to come to terms with it and
once you do you actually don't need them
to do anything for you but the truth of
the matter is is that our childhood
plays an enormous role
on
what how we act in the world and what we
judge and what what we are what we end
up projecting against and what triggers
us i can give you an analogy so um
i think it's really important
when you
decide that you're going to
change your habits and change the
patterns of behavior
that make you feel stuck or that you
can't stand anymore that are the result
of surviving trauma you got to be
compassionate with yourself and patient
because a great analogy
for the patterns that you learned that
you're now stuck with right now it feels
like as an adult is this
you spent how many years
as a race car driver
how many years how many 27 years imagine
if when you retired i said okay
you're gonna play football now
and i expect you
to be the best
that's tall order i mean that's an
overwhelming prop proposal you know
yes
it's going to take years for you to
learn
a brand new sport
and it's going to take
small daily practice and studying
and being patient with yourself to build
new muscles and skills and the truth is
you might never
fully
build new muscles and skills it might
never come easily or naturally but over
time you could learn to be an excellent
football player
but what you have to have compassion for
is the fact that for the first 27 years
you were not playing football you were
driving a race car
and those are very different patterns
so if you're going to go from a
situation where you have a pattern of
withdrawing
into yourself or lying or snapping at
people or whatever your pattern is in
response to uncertainty
it's literally the equivalent of
teaching yourself to go from being a
professional race car driver to a
professional football player
foreign totally different skills totally
different
neural pathways and so when you kind of
understand that that you can do it but
it's going to take time and i think one
of the things that was the most
eye-opening thing that i have ever
learned was this um and i only learned
this recently
one of the reasons why behavior change
is so frustrating and it's so hard and
you've got to use all these tools in
order to trick your brain and to plow
new neural pathways in and to form new
habits
the reason why it's so hard is because
when you and i are talking about
changing our behavior or we're talking
about trauma pattern or we're talking
about the [ __ ] that we do that we'd want
to change we're really frustrated by
we're using the conscious part of our
brain we're using the prefrontal cortex
talking about behavior change is easy to
do the reason why it's so difficult is
you and i can sit here and talk about it
and we can make a plan for it and we can
say okay the next time that that you're
in a situation where your husband gives
you that look and then you start to
worry that uh you know
is going to happen you feel the rage
come up in your body like what used to
drive me bananas is my husband would ask
me a ton of questions
and in my opinion they're obvious stupid
questions and so you know i of course
feel like a royal [ __ ] now because
we've come to find out that my husband
has been struggling with long-term
depression and one of the reasons why he
has a brain you know why his brain is so
foggy is because of depression
and it didn't help that he was smoking a
ton of weed all the time too and so you
know i would literally get so frustrated
because he would we'd be talking about
something and he would be like
uh well i don't know what do you what do
you think like just asking questions and
i'm like you should know the answer to
that
have you heard of google why are you
asking me what the weather is going to
be you know tomorrow in vermont [ __ ]
google like you're like and i'd go like
ah
and i hated that about myself
hated it and i would talk to my
therapist i can't snap at him i don't
want like i i i need to be more patient
you know this is what my mom did like
she would get frustrated with my father
and now i'm doing it with chris and i
don't want to be that person
oh my god i would talk about this topic
probably for years
and i would make a plan to become and
i'd make a plan to put myself in pause
and then the next day or two
i'd get back in my life
and we'd be standing there having a
conversation
and he would ask me a question
that i think he should have googled or
should know the answer to and then the
rage would come
and it wasn't until i learned the fact
that i was talking about the behavior
that i wanted to change with this part
of my brain
but the rage and the impatience and the
kind of like ah the kind of like
emotional reactiveness
that pattern is stored here
in the basal ganglia
that pattern operates
in my subconscious
and that pattern is not initiated by
thinking
that pattern is initiated by emotions
that rise up in the body
and it's only when you realize that the
behavior change particularly when it
comes to generational patterns and
trauma patterns
that in order to catch it
you've got to not only
figure out the pattern you want to
change but you've got to figure out the
situations and the emotions that you're
feeling in your body
that
correspond to the pattern
that you want to change
because when i start to feel my ankles
getting hot
i know that that feeling in my body that
emotion of frustration
that is the trigger